Rodney Dangerfield to you his a
father-figure oh yeah he was so good to
you and so encouraging to you that even
nights where you thought you were
bombing as a stand-up comic Rodney would
say you are a funny [ __ ] he was
really mean he was always there for me I
always supported me even when I was
experimenting and no one knew what the
hell I was doing he was there for me he
still hired me he sat in the wings with
his balls hanging out of his you know
robe on the side of the stage just
howling with laughter and I get off and
he'd say man they're looking at you like
you from another [ __ ] planet hey Jim
all the impressions you do was Rodney's
favorite impression truly the amazing
Kreskin did you do an impression up
because I love it it's like coming
coming up and saying like hi the amazing
Kreskin
nice to meet you like and I'd shake
somebody's hand in the front row we've
never met before heavily like that and
I'd take their hand and I just keep
shaking it and he shook hands so hard
then I'd start doing it and it would
just like it just would grow into total
manic insane energy and he it used to
crack people up and and yeah he used to
make fun of me because it was not a
well-known impression in the States so I
had to come up with some other stuff
when Rodney was dying you did talk to
him in the hospital yeah yeah and and
you were you see this is the balls on
you guys he means something to you what
was it you said to Rodney about you were
gonna go now tell the world he's a bit
worried I'll I'll let everybody know
that you were gay
it's it's anymore and he was kind of
staring off into space and there was no
action on the machines or anything like
that
and at that point his eyes kind of
shifted and his mouth started shaking
like he wanted to say something to me
and he was like Indian I could see there
was a look of like joy and recognition
and stuff and and all the machines lit
up and this crash team ran into the room
and said what the hell is going on and
stuff and they said it got it he hasn't
shown any signs like that in a long time
so he knew who was there